[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est le début du marathon
des repas de noël
on commence aujourd'hui le dimanche 18
décembre vous écouter no one extrait du
nouvel album de little guerrier bon
bilan des courses repas de noël très
sympa maintenant on continue pour le
reste de la journée
alors là on en bagnole direction le
match avec mélanie c'est mon premier
match en premier
quinze ans après pour y arriver
toutefois c'est chiant je te vois ce
goût [ __ ] c'est compliqué trouver sa
place dans un stade en est qu à nous
deux mais alors c'est par la simple joie
faut courir on est quoi emploie 134 a
tant fait rien c'est compliqué c'est la
seule à salonique est arrivé bonjour
je savais pas aussi tout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors
alors ce match
[Musique]
ça y est roi
on veut le dire oui et il en a les
enfants des jumeaux comment t'as fait
j'ai tout donné
anti vagin c'est grâce à ma femme donc
on à battisti sic et pharmacia qu'est le
dj du rp h 15 rassemblement d'étudiants
en pharmacie
là on a
la tête pensante la suite transformé
l'eau qui est aussi un pharmacien qui
n'a rien à voir que leur ph mais qui
sera là les deux premiers soirs
ceux qui connaissent pas leur ph c de la
boucherie voilà c'est la boucherie entre
étudiants c'est un truc extraordinaire
mais c'est réservé pour les initiés
[Musique]
j'écoute leçon à qui est qu elle est
venue me sens où les saab ou fermées
récent n'a rien d'un kop bien à 19
heures la bonne vieille cocotte secret
c'est pourquoi taiko cote dans le corps
parce que la bouche en sur l'a75 une
cocotte se creuse globalement quoi qu'il
se passe tu peux manger quoi toujours ça
n'a aucun sens n'a aucun sens alors les
musiques du blog du blog la musique du
loch sont très corrects premier vlok
deuxième blog somme toute un petit peu
érotique amusé le troisième blog me
paraît très performant moi c'est un peu
s'y prendre du match très beau match
même si non ce cahier les couilles haut
rendement qui avec le vin chaud entendu
le la cocotte d'amener les kombouare un
petit coup avec l est
au marché de noël la vache vous avez
loupé un truc ya même des nains elfes
pour monter son chien dont le dans la
bay elle ne dira pas le cas par la
laisse les chiens les films à voir si sa
ou ses peintures un peu d'eau bon il est
temps d'aller faire un petit tour du
côté du marché de noël
qu'est ce tu manges l'a28 plaisir est la
différence entre une vitrine moule
gameiro maintenant ça fait manger keller
et dire 19h16
et quel jour sommes à peu près toujours
le 26 mai dans une semaine c'est noël
tous courante est prêt ou pas en 2014
toujours à l'affût de noël à courir tout
fait toujours tout seul non avec arthur
je sais pas si arthur cette année à une
émission de télé pour la souvent ils le
faire tu as est sympa avec moi mais
sympa start i could gel et ce afin de
réussite on va boire du vin chaud oui
c'est bientôt la fusion ce n'est pas
parce que nous avons deux gardiens
pourquoi samedi soir
[Musique]